in the lobby of Ramsey solutions rich
and Janice are with us hey guys how are
you dad you doing dude
welcome where y'all from we are from the
Boston Massachusetts area awesome
Oh welcome it's good to have you thanks
and the young ladies you brought with
you names and ages this is Sofie age 12
and Chelsea age 10 Wow awesome beautiful
family thank you well thanks for
dropping by all the way from Boston to
do your debt-free scream here in
Nashville how much have you paid off
paid off three hundred seventy six
thousand dollars oh just like that just
like that how long did that take about
four years Wow household income range
during that four years one-ninety ended
about 225 excellent what do you guys do
for a living I have my own management
consulting company mm-hmm and I worked
in health care finance oh very good to
excellent careers very good fun fun fun
so 376 what kind of debt was that oh
well it was pretty much everything you
tell people not to do we had a septic
loan we had to put a new septic system
in and everyone told us how great it
would be if we get this low-interest
loan you know we had a new car loan
bought a new car that was that was on
the list we had a home equity loan and
the house oh you paid off your house
paid out that everything everything Wow
what's this house worth uh embarrassed
to say it's worth about six hundred
twenty-five thousand why are you
embarrassed
I you know Dave this is one of the
funniest things this process that we've
gone through we actually are embarrassed
to tell people that we don't have a home
mortgage and that you're winning and
that we're winning it is someone asked
me what your interest rate on your
mortgage and it was two days after we
had paid off our mortgage and I paused
and I looked at the person with the
blank stare and said I don't have a
mortgage first time it really hit me
that this had really sunk in that's fun
yeah some people will think you're
bragging but most pee
we'll be happy for you right that's what
it comes down to when you're winning and
there's some people they're gonna be
jealous no matter what you do when
you're winning and you're winning really
great you got great incomes you get a
beautiful family the house is paid for
life is good way to go you guys I'm so
proud of you this is awesome very cool
very cool
now what started this process four years
ago good so rich was looking for a
podcast to listen to before he went to
bed and stumbled upon your show uh-huh
and that was it you know the old Google
search mechanism yeah one of my best
promotion to tell you that random
selection by God so that you got wore
out with a podcast
hour after hour after hour of this voice
okay and and he starts talking to you
about this Janice what was he saying to
you said you know stuff that he's saying
just make sense and it sounds like the
opposite of what everybody that we know
is doing mm-hmm but what you get on the
other end is the sense of complete peace
and flexibility mm-hmm not being tied to
the job you're in because you have a
mortgage you have to pay for and I
thought sounded really good yeah just to
get to do what you want to do because
you want to do it exactly right now
that's very cool that's fun well it is
there's there's a sense of power and
sense of control by not having a payment
in the world right you know what you can
do when you don't have any payment say
anything you want that's fun so if
someone were to ask other than the blank
stare how you got out of debt what would
you tell them the keys are to getting
out of debt yeah I think you know the
biggest thing is and you were talking I
was listening to one of the last callers
is a vision and and the reason we're in
this lobby today is is we would actually
play the debt free screams for the kids
I would say this is what we're going to
do we're gonna go to Nashville we're
gonna stand there goofy the headsets
with
but we're gonna do this and and here's
why we're doing this and here's what it
means to our family here's what it means
to our life and and that vision and we
just kept pounding it and pounding it
and pounding at home saying and I think
you know we were talking about this when
we had 37 dollars in the checking
account I think about that she's making
almost $200,000 a year now and you have
37 dollars and I have to tell Janice do
not spend a dime for the next 24 hours
until the next the next direct deposit
comes in so yeah you gotta have the
vision and you get a hat you just got to
say we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
so the girls have been looking forward
to the debt-free scream because that was
the vision that was laid out there right
how much of this do they really grasp
how much of you have you talked it
through with them we talk about this a
lot with them we've been talking with
them for years about the fact that you
know despite what everybody around us is
doing we're not gonna do things like
spend whatever amount it takes to send
them to whatever college they want so I
think they get the message and it
doesn't seem to bother them at all no
and none of them have a twitch so
they're good you know the big thing is
this idea of you know if you work you
get money and if you get money you can
do things and that the the opposite if
you don't work you don't get money and
if you don't have money you can't buy
things and I mean I think you guys would
agree that that's sort of the the
message we keep sending is is you know
we we actually hope that we're we're
doing them a favor oh you are you know
what I was actually called a bad parent
one time because I said I would not take
out a student you know cosign alone
which basically is me yeah signing for a
loan when you consider the source though
you that said that it pretty much
guarantees that you're not a bad parent
right you look in the eyes of that
person and there's I mean there's nobody
home nobody's even coming up the
driveway I mean
you know that's stupid right so yeah
they sometimes worry we've gone the
other direction though we have to
encourage them to spend their money yeah
right now that's okay and that's the
culture we'll take care of that you
don't worry about it right the cultural
influence will take care of the other
side of that you want to sweat that at
all if you can keep them saving and
generous they won't have any trouble
spending right so and if they do then
then you can work on it a little bit but
it's it's it's an interesting process so
it's important that you've paid off
three hundred seventy six thousand
dollars in four years but what's more
important is you have completely changed
your family tree because this has
changed the mathematical financial value
system DNA of your family yeah
absolutely and I think you know the
biggest thing for example just to put a
plug in for an organization that we that
we we actually as a family raise about
ten to twelve thousand dollars a year to
buy backpacks for kids and homeless
shelters awesome and the reason I
mentioned that is it it's a hundred
percent volunteer organization it's not
Christmas in the city but Christmas in
the first was in the city org and we do
that as a way to teach the kids hey look
you know we have an obligation to
support the greater good here okay so
and the funny thing is it costs us
nothing to do that to stand out in front
of a supermarket for four or five hours
on a Saturday and they'll say oh our
feet are tired you know that's good
that's good your feet are tired I hope
you have a lot of blisters when you know
that's a good thing because we're trying
to teach some hard work their values and
really be sort of good citizens of a lot
yeah I'm very proud of you guys we're
gonna have a copy handed to you of
retire inspired by Chris Hogan Thank You
number one best national bestseller
because that's the next phase for you
guys to live and give like no one else
you're you're definitely in the mode to
do that rich and Janice Sophie and
Chelsea Boston Massachusetts it's three
hundred and seventy six thousand dollars
paid off in four years making one ninety
two to twenty five count it down goofy
head sets it off let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
I love it I love it I love it
well done very well done that's fabulous
proud of you guys
now cat make sure they get their retire
inspired book out there and life is good
this is how you do it guys
the next step then you get clear that
you use the muscle the financial muscle
that is freed up your most powerful
wealth building tool which is your
income now you can do some heavy lifting
now you can build some wealth now you
can do some generous things that aren't
five dollars or ten dollars all those
are nice but 5,000 and 10,000 battery
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you